back in 1995 you thought I really like
Tim Burton and Joel Schumacher made Lost
Boys which no one realizes is terrible
yet so maybe I can get into this that
bulge DC Comics can I persuade you to
take a sandwich with you sir I'll get
drive-thru ah jokey Batman is back
ladies and gentlemen it's why we flocked
so hard to the Tim Burton was right Joel
Schumacher Dutch angles the shit out of
this downtown crime scene
this ain't your Big Brother's Batman
folks Harvey Dent is looking
considerably whiter than the last time I
saw him I'm fine with not seeing his
origin story even though this entire
series shows every villains
transformation except his I just want to
know what happened a Billy Dee Williams
man the director said Nicole just make
the face you made the first time you saw
Tom Cruise's bank account balance the
second Bank of Gotham on the second
anniversary of the day I captured him
how could two-face resist to overload
she specializes in normal psychology
Batman is a dick to people finishing
their sentences insightful naive but
insightful bat handed compliments to
face somehow new this demolition ball
would come within 12 inches of him
without hurting the guy is Batman do you
think this simple shoot the elevator
trick has a chance
whatever happens during a thing and an
incident occurs oh man you just made me
think of general Akbar which makes me
think of Lando Calrissian which makes me
even sadder that Billy Dee didn't make
it into this movie Oh No
I can definitely tell what it is by
sight and can narrate it also you could
at least made the acid fall from a
different height so that would be
pouring on them right now instead of
below them where you have to wait for
the safe to fill up before it does
damage how convenient
if only to face had killed you instead
of the other two guys then this stupid
plan would worked you ever watch a movie
with a victim you actually hope doesn't
make it psychiatrist chase meridian is
among the first police officers on the
scene wait she's not a fucking cop
Gotham is looking considerably more
statuesque statue philic maybe than the
last time I saw it everyone survives
this two-face takes an empty dangling
chained I mean the Batman is definitely
dead Gotham a metaphorical stand-in for
New York City is literally turned into
New York City and of course Statue of
Liberty is destroyed rip off Gotham
Statue of Liberty's face resembles mine
after watching this movies first 12
minutes the clutter of this Gotham is
insane but mostly the problem is that it
looks fake Edward nygma has a serial
killer style Bruce Wayne try inside
Wayne Enterprises Edward nygma my
parents knew I would need a Riddler s
name when I was born so your name was
Bruce Wayne for all his genius does not
have particularly good hiring standards
Jerry I wonder how many times Bruce is
accidentally falling down the tunnel
with this voice command geez if any
asshole can use this signal then surely
other assholes could lure Batman to this
rooftop and try to ambush it you know
without concocting a safe full of acid
plant his coin it's his Achilles heel
you did not notice two faces fucking
coin you were all the way down here
furthermore his Achilles heel is that he
comes up with stupid-ass plans not the
coin flipping the bat signal is not a
beeper well I wish I could say that my
interest in you was purely professional
daddy call that just happened in a
goddamn Batman movie you like strong
women I've done my own work or do I need
skin type vinyl I know well being
Michelle Pfeiffer helps to one man
that's racist Kaffee ladies and
gentlemen Riddler Ventura mask detective
everything about now the schumacher
Batman's are shot tell you we shot this
in an abandoned studio after the haunted
house tour was over you remember that
movie Atwood that I can't remember who
directed and then I'm too lazy to go
check IMDB for reference it's kind of
like what Tim Burton was telling us
about Ed Wood
bubyee unintentionally scripts the best
scene from Bruce Almighty eight years
ahead of time movie turns actual genius
Riddler character into cartoon of a geek
you are going up on charges the court
fred threatens a clearly psychotic
person while tied to a chair
nygma shoves his boss here and then
appears shotgun surprise when his boss
doesn't go over the edge my question is
why did he not remove the helmet on his
boss that is clearly half the reason his
invention works he's gonna need that
wait does Wayne Enterprises also serve
as a dam where is the water source
pumping through Gotham instead of
killing his boss nygma chooses to let
gravity decide this was horribly scarred
by underworld kingpins who despite lack
security decided to smuggle a bottle of
acid instead of a gun into the courtroom
also GNN was there covering the case and
was able to set up multi camera coverage
of the event to capture all the angles
you know because he's also Batman in the
middle of the day and shows up regularly
to court he was there and despite the
obvious way Maroni was preparing this
attack Batman was slowest he was like my
other fan you don't realize until you
rewatch this thing how egregious that
Jim Carrey nosov it all really is this
is last night's security long did nygma
create video footage that does not exist
I understand maybe erasing the footage
but this is some Bulls beer even for
this fucking movie if you look at the
numbers on my face you won't find 13
anyplace the answer is a clock well
clearly you and the Riddler haven't read
1984 Bruce who would send you a riddle
that Maggie yeah because it certainly
wasn't that easy clock bull criss cross
we'll make it wash dry
oh man they drag the Flaming Lips into
this didn't they good thing nygma was
already obsessed with a specific green
question mark costume prior to his
transformation into the Riddler whew
that's pretty handy actually outside of
Wayne Manor does not capture video
footage of nygma delivering Riddler
letter somehow I don't need to be a dick
but custom question mark printed mailing
envelopes how is thing but not busted
already I mean he obviously went to
Kinko's obvious sounds of punching a
heavy bag come from chases office but
Bruce will knock the door down trying to
save her because Batman is terrible at
hearing but it's obviously a bat so shut
your psychology track tell me doctor do
you like the circus so this 3 minute
scene where Bruce asked questions he
already knew the answer to was just so
he could ask chase out an earlier chase
wasted everyone's time telling him stuff
he already knew to seduce him will you
guys just go ahead and already hey it's
1995 as Jurassic Park come out and
dazzled with visual and practical
effects yet it has let's go the other
direction
fake as possible oh good more origin
stories I was just sitting here thinking
man this movie is good but it would be
great if there was yet another character
in it I've met someone that's fast work
not really
she's Nicole Kidman I heard Chris
O'Donnell spent hours doing close-ups so
they could cover up the fact that he
couldn't do any of this acrobatics in
the movie which would have been awesome
to use against Batman earlier when he
was trapped in a safe but I went with
acid prank
maybe the crowd is loud but your date
right next to you heard that and on the
other side is the gossip columnist so
know it will then take another 20
seconds for this countdown clock to
advance five seconds and another 12
seconds for the thing to detonate that
was 200 sticks of TNT okay whatever you
say a movie that hates my guts
my stupid heroic no net Flying Circus
family members are dead after we all
helped save the day face the circus must
be halfway to Metropolis oh wow it's not
a Batman movie if we're not
unnecessarily reminded that Bruce's
parents were murdered is this nope it's
a Nightwing but those things get
confused from time to time my father
said it was this hero
I flew in like a Robin Robins of course
being known for their amazing bravery
and can-do attitude
Joe father was right you had a hit I can
tell because of the earring now that
we've taken care of Robin and why his
name is Robin and we've learned all the
Robin things
here's secondary character Batman
fighting crime against two-bit villain
two-face
by the way what even got Batman out here
we know he was bat-signal but how did he
end up getting chased by two faces men
in some back alley somewhere that Robin
was so important I guess it glossed over
the reason why Batman was even called in
the first place sure is sweet Gotham is
made of 80% statues and grotesques
because one comes in handy at the top of
some random wall at the end of an alley
I don't know why such a decoration would
be here but it seems to work for Batman
and that's what counts
cars unable to catch up to Batman decide
he'll just run into the wall then each
other and Batman can outrun a fireball
question mark man
nepotism this is some of the worst fake
typing I've ever seen an actor try to
get away with a side of raw donkey meat
man Batman shouldn't even worry about
taking out this asshole he's dead in a
matter of days strictly due to diet why
not she really ate him first
Riddler comes up with an idea to join
forces with two-faced and humiliate
Batman of course I thought edward
nygma's beef was with Bruce Wayne and he
doesn't know Wayne is Batman yet but
excuse to get the two villains together
is excuse villain team-up scene
unintentionally helps up spider-man
three whoa whoa oh he strode in here
with nothing but a cane two minutes ago
are you telling me he pre hid his
mind-control devices in Harvey's lair so
he could pick them up dramatically here
well good thing these diametrically
opposed to face bimbos both have wp own
properties on their mind this is how I
found you
let me demonstrate that doesn't answer
the question you've had to set this up
somewhere to read two faces mind which
means you would have had to know where
to find two-face in the first place
and we accept and Tails I wonder what it
lands on oh man they're gonna keep us in
suspense something no movie from 1995
dares to show you fast-paced ninja
laundry sessions like Batman Forever
that wink is for the film editor another
robbery perpetrated by the city's green
sooted Menace resulting in millions in
diamonds stolen with no sign of Batman
yeah why is that what the hell is Bruce
Wayne been doing the past two nights
I'll tell you what he's at home watching
his tights also news media blames
Riddler for all these robberies but
apparently no one ever saw
two-face in the middle of all this this
new criminals pattern of marking his
crimes with puzzles as Gothamites
calling him the Riddler oh they
collectively chose for him the same name
he picked for himself that's amazing the
age of us go forth north back to protect
our King from the foes attack this
riddle is so easy it might as well be an
instruction in the rules of chess
how did this lava lamp blender thing
with thins ever get named the box edward
nygma's 3d box has become the rage of
Gotham and no other city for some reason
present-day sci fi could slide this
right into their original movie slate
alongside sharknado and croctopus' and
no one would notice it takes so long for
this door to the Batcave to close it can
do all the stunts that killed his family
and still make it in in time during an
intruder alert the Batmobile platform
still decides to rise and expose the
Batmobile as if it wants to confirm
proof of Batman
dr. chase meridian apparently lives
inside a giant long with a huge mural of
an elf with breasts on the wall because
Schumacher my dreams are coming to me
man mo and now those are called memories
Bruce Owen flashbacks Iceman maverick
will not be pleased at this development
actually he took the car dick was still
able to get in the Batmobile and drive
it even with the intruder alert or
security ever movie will not once try to
explain how or why an aerial circus
performer is a master of hand-to-hand
combat two-face blames Batman for being
two-faced Robin blames Batman for
two-face killing his family
hashtag Obama but first I'm a part of
this whether you like it or not and to
prove that I'm part of this I'm now
going to run up the steps away from this
edwards whatever I'm about to say will
require the removal of my glasses
movie inadvertently inspires facebook
also Batman's brain is the opening
credits of the future spider-man duo
Fox's ex machina we're sick of waiting
for you to deliver the Batman yeah
because delivering the Batman is on a
strict timetable that just couldn't wait
random ass two-faced minions are so
laughably bad they should have just
shown Batman's entrance and cut straight
to the next shot with all of them
writhing on the floor Batman steals the
Indiana Jones from Raiders of the Lost
Ark when you see how far Batman has to
jump to get down here there's no way
this asshole sees it so two-face
concocted a plan to get Batman to jump
into this work area amazingly it works
and what does he decide to do the mother
tries to burn him with flaming gas this
is one of the most inept Criminal Minds
we have ever seen Batman invented a cape
that he should have donated to every
fireman in the city instead it's for his
own convenient personal use just this
one time
never seen before or since because
you're worse than a Bond villain
Batman survives this bull guy who just
been moaned how Batman never dies is now
going to leave without checking to make
sure Batman died
happy music make me angry wherever this
asshole came from never be moved before
oh ooh burn on Vicki Vale and Selina
Kyle what's so special about dr. chase
meridian nothing we've seen in this
movie so far suggests he's any better
than those two previous women yeah I
probably should look into the sound
chase feels about me situation before
trying to learn any more about to face
and the Riddler yeah but why didn't the
person you know as Bruce Wayne leave you
at a party while two-face shot the place
up Bruce never returned either so either
you should have already figured this out
or your feelings are for a guy who
abandons you at the first sign of
trouble
either way sin for me understand just to
clarify this girl has broken up with
Bruce Wayne because she had a lady boner
for Batman and now she's breaking up
with Batman because she has a lady boner
for Bruce Wayne this article on the left
is about a penny sales tax but I'd like
to meet this prodigy child who won every
award given did he win the Oscar I bet
he won the Oscar also this main article
about to face Robin nygma tech is
actually about the murder of Bruce
Wayne's parents which is weirdly wrong
but close to the main topic and the
article on the right is the same
identical thing if you do find Harvey
and then you kill him what next I feel
like we've been over this territory
twice already we get it already
Bruce's mansion is way out in the bum
count stretches of Gotham who the fuck
is coming out here for trick-or-treating
oh I would Bruce have any roses in his
house if he's gonna flip out at the mere
sight of them falling to the ground
triggering his painful childhood
memories this two-faced vehicle
approaching reminds me how did the kids
at the door getting candy right now and
get past the closed iron gate security
at Wayne Manor continues to be a sore
spot even after an asshole named The
Riddler taped the riddle to his gate
earlier in the movie do you think you
might want to plunk some change into a
gate camera Brucie all righty then
meanwhile these kids are walking miles
from their homes to trick-or-treat here
with nobody driving them around and with
no adult supervision this asshole is
still flashing back and she's still
worried about the mess she made we just
saw trick-or-treaters come up to the
door get their candy and leave how is
this still happening
down into what is now known as the
Batcave no one ever knew it was there
despite the giant gaping hole in the
ground in there deep in the shadows
he was amazingly well lit for being
underground and well it's dark outside
and while it's raining I saw it was
coming toward me and for whatever reason
there was a giant spotlight shining in
my eyes at the top
I wouldn't sure what happened to me
would never happen to anyone else again
except Robin in this movie what are you
trying to tell me well it doesn't matter
not in the least curious just put it
inside me people has major design flaws
but isn't it super lucky they found out
Bruce's secret just in time for
Halloween and the house apparently gets
pound of trick-or-treaters the last time
this intruder alert happened the
computers came on by themselves and the
Batmobile arrived like it wanted to
spill the beans
now the Riddler has to turn it on using
this bullsh Kane thing and if you want
to tell me Alfred was the one who turned
on the computers last time why did he do
it after the alarm sounded the two-face
intend to graze Bruce's forehead with
his shot because that's the most amazing
shot ever if that's the case god damn it
had to face who has been nothing but
obsessed with killing Batman and knows
Bruce Wayne is Batman and is completely
exposed it's just going to allow this
perhaps one and eight or 1818 is about
mr. e mr. e it's kind of bull how you
guys came to this conclusion especially
since you had to figure out that the 1
and the 8 are actually 18 but just being
a little observant or having a security
camera outside would have solved this
mystery thing a long time ago
that ass I see we're by ear why not both
in no world did you hear the question
Batman just asked from wherever you are
also how did the Riddler miss these
things when he was bombing the entire
Batcave earlier who's your tailor I took
the Liberty sir what are you saying that
after dick ran away from the mansion you
built a suit for him because remember
when he left he took the 1960s clothes
with him and you didn't have any new
suit lying around at the time so you
knew he'd be back
you just said master dick has run away
just a couple hours ago ah
what's that stand for a word no one's
allowed to use any more after tropic the
Robin oh right it's that it's Robin
these guys went from shooting our Poon's
trying to kill Robin to just trying to
apprehend him which allows Batman time
for his lunacy rescue plan also Batman
turned his plane into a submarine just
to drive two forward three feet and
eject himself evil guy rubs his hands
together to accentuate his evilness
cliche holy rusted metal Batman grout
it's all metal it's full of holes you
holy
well now it's dingy I mean dingy why did
two-face even bother to come out here
Batman is the guy he wants but as if he
knows dick has a hard-on for revenge he
comes out here to fight Robin the four
by me it might be tempted to blame Tommy
Lee Jones his performance on the general
camp of the movie but this is way too
far even for this movie he's out Jim
carrying Jim Carrey man only partner you
set all this up so that Batman would
have to choose to save chaser Robin this
was your plan all along
ever since you prevented two-face from
killing him when he had the chance but
you couldn't possibly have known that
Robin was Batman's partner because even
Batman didn't know until like ten
minutes ago you weren't around when
Robin saved Batman from that pile of
rocks earlier either so this bullsh plan
cannot be not enough time to save them
both in one scene movie inspires
spider-man The Dark Knight The Matrix
Reloaded and countless other movies good
and bad to do the force the hero to
choose between saving two things routine
wait I have a riddle for you
for me this works I see without seeing
even if you're concentrating really hard
on this riddle the stuff Batman is doing
is way too obvious to ignore yeah well
if you actually had the ability to kill
anyone this might be a decent talk as
such it's not I'd wonder how hard he got
down here so fast since he was up top
with them and they had to basically
freefall to get here this fast but
what's the damn point I understand that
man might come up with the idea to make
a replica two-face coin to use in some
small odds attack against the villain
but like dozens of them also that's
murder Batman knew what would happen
when he tossed the coins and then did
nothing to try and save Harvey but
whatever fun campy movie Oh
[Music]
you've tried killing him like one time
this movie poor Edward I had to save
them both but the only reason you were
able to save them both it's because of
Riddler's stupid designs to have them
fall in the same tunnel through two
separate holes doctor tells me director
of the previous two Batman movies is
reduced to a character played by another
actor in the third Batman film and they
lived happily ever after
we asked this last time where is this
where would they be running that has the
bat-signal shining horizontally down
some tunnel nowhere that's where
ever since cinemasins began the most
requested thing has been TV since and
now it's a reality click the link in the
description below to check it out and
now the audio outtakes call it I can't
call it for you
[Music]
you
feeling two-faced won't take the pain
away make it worse fade away like our
previous winners Whitman price and
Haddad you remember them there they are
into this very moment they're basking
under the Maui stunned I've met someone
he's he's not you want me even if it was
only for
I was ready to give up everything so
from this day on I'm spider-man
no me wait a minute wait a minute it's
party time
pa rt why because I gotta